now that we've talked about the data
repository specifically we can talk
about the wolf the resource system is
also as you can see the data repository
was a system for distributing data
through the Wolfram language and through
our cloud but we can do much more than
data so the resource system is that is
going to have lots of repositories each
one defined by their particular content
so if so you know each each it will be
defined in two repositories and
resources and the parts so what we're
going to talk about we're gonna talk
about terminology a little bit when you
talk about publisher accounts and what
you need to submit for a publication and
then we're going to spend most of the
rest of time talking about these there's
four repositories besides data since we
are talking about that and really we're
just glad it's over a neural net so
we'll look at three new ones that are
coming demonstration repository function
repository formula repository and then
we'll have another demo of creating your
own resource this time instead of data
we're going to look at function
resources and then a brief preview of
what what's coming in the future for the
resource system so the resource system
is divided into bra stories like I said
each one having its own content type so
we already saw data content and we're
gonna see a lot about neural network
content later and in general
repositories that have websites they
have functions that integrate them into
Wolfram language different resource
types are integrated in different ways
and they have metadata that's specific
to the to the repository
we already saw this for what a resource
object is and how to look at its
metadata so we won't necessarily go into
that again here so but what we should
talk about now is publisher IDs which I
alluded to before if you want to submit
what you need to do is request a
publisher ID you can do that on the data
repository website here just tell us who
you are and what you want to do with
your publisher ID
and once and then your that'll be
reviewed by by someone at Wolfram and
well and if we like what you want to
publish and then we'll give you a
publisher ID and once you have that it's
not limited to just the data repository
even though that's where the form is you
can submit a neural network or function
once that once that's live or any
resource type so in addition to
reviewing requests republished IDs we
also have human beings that are that
will review the submissions for of
resources to see what we want to include
and I talked a little bit about what
we're looking for for data um so data
repository you know that was released
almost a year ago now and the content is
data we already spent 20 minutes 30
minutes looking at that specifically so
we won't dwell on that the the next
repository is the neural net repository
I won't go too deep here because Megan's
gonna go in-depth in her talk that's
coming up after this so feel free to
play around with this example in in the
notebook that's been distributed but I
will just point out that you know all of
these repositories have this share a
share the interface of using resource
objects so you can get a resource object
you can use the name in here it's a
neural net resource instead of a data
resource there's some metadata that's
consistent between all resource types
like details is a consistent text field
for all resource types they're you know
content elements is consistent between
neural networks and data resources
resource data is the same it works the
same for neural networks as it did for
data of resources but it won't
necessarily be that way for all
resources as we'll see so this sort of
gets the the net chain and I won't go
any further because that might might
spoil Megan's talk
that the third repository which is kind
of slowly quietly being released as we
move on is the the demonstrations
repository so the demonstration project
has been around for a decade and it's
great and there's great content here
it's you know this is all user generated
dynamic content that creates manipulate
objects or animation objects that show
great things one drawback of it though
has been that yeah there's this website
where in order to actually here's the
thing you need there download a CDF or
you download a notebook and there's no
one's really it's not clear how do you
do this so the interface with the
Wolfram language could be better now
that we have the resource system so
that's that's sort what we've been doing
so so now you can just take the name of
the demonstration and put in a resource
object you can just like we've seen
before you can see metadata authoring
information is one that we have for
demonstrations that was different than
what we had notes and data resources and
you know we have the symbols views which
is kind of neat this is a new metadata
field that we've added that shows you
all the symbols that that the author
used to create the demonstration and
then using resource data gives you the
actual animation so this is much nicer
than you know downloading a CDF or or a
notebook that adds a whole bunch of
stuff you might not care about in it you
can just sort of go straight to the main
event which here is this manipulate so
so that and so there's over 10,000
demonstrations we've been gradually
moving them over to the resource system
since there's there's some manual
extensions that were doing to the
metadata it takes a little bit of time
so we've probably got two or three
thousand done and they're slowly being
migrated over but
this is using the resource system to add
Wolfram language integration to a
website that's already existed formula
data is the opposite story so formula
data has been around for a couple
versions of Wolfram language now and
it's it's got a thousand formulas in it
if you've used if you've used formula
data you know this is this is not
particularly interesting to you because
this is sort of a thing that we've had
already you can see a table you can
apply values to it and get results but
what we're doing what the resource
system is allowed us to do with this is
to add a web interface to the Wolfram
language content that's existed already
so if we we can look at a preview of
what this is going to look like so this
this is this is hot off the presses this
is not publicly released yet so I guess
it's not off the presses on the way to
the presses and so this is what the
formula repository will look like soon
so you can look at within these domains
you can see give me something from the
domain of physics that has an equation
involving mass and hmm so this okay so
okay there we go we only have one with
mass but you know gravitational
acceleration I'm surprised there's not
more with mass in physics so so and just
like just like the other ones each
resource has its own page where there's
a name and a description and more
details and you know you can do things
like copy the the formula directly into
a notebook soaping a new notebook and
just stick it in here you can see here's
here's this set of equations describing
I don't even know what a polytropic
process is but I can learn about it's a
thermodynamic state but then the
interesting thing is we have these forms
so
all right let's let's just change change
a bunch of these things from what what
it's suggesting change units around and
you can mix things up
we can combine English and standard if
I'm putting in things that are
ridiculous here tell them let me know
who I'll just do that one I'm not gonna
I can submit this thing and I should get
okay so this is why it's still coming
along because some of these some of
these formatting are there but it this
is this is correct it's just formatted
poorly but you can you can get your
numeric results for these these forums
right away just in a web form that's out
there and again these have examples that
right on the right on the website so you
know how to use it and you can open the
notebook in the Wolfram cloud or you can
download an example notebook so let's
look at that we can take that guy and
immediately open it up in so we have the
same examples here so so the the the
formula resource
unlike date unlike demonstrations where
we were adding Wolfram language
integration to the website that are
existent here we're using introducing a
web interface to Wolfram language
functionality that are existent
so the last repository is one that I
think people are going to be excited
about that's the function repository
which is going to allow you to sort of
extend the Wolfram language with
functions that for one reason or another
we don't really think are worthy of
putting into the top-level Wolfram
language so there can be simple utility
functions here's one that we have called
lookup sequence if you're familiar with
look up it sort of works on the first
level of a data set yeah we won't look
at the documentation it sort of looks at
an association at the first level this
is something that we've made that can go
deeper parts so what this works is you
take resource function on the resource
object and you get this little blob if
you have some nested data structure you
can you can use this blob and apply it
to the data and you can say that
Suzanne's hobbies are playing poker but
fred has no hobbies so he's boring you
can supply this t-phone so this is a
little utility function that might not
be worth being a system-level Wolfram
language function there might be
something that we put into the function
repository another thing that we could
put in there is something that's a
little like more esoteric or has a
narrower usage-based and maybe though
everyone who uses Wolfram language so
here's something that we're calling
symbol dependency graph so this takes a
symbol and shows you what other symbols
it depends on and builds a graph out of
the dependencies so here a depends on B
and C B depends on C and C doesn't
depend on anything so you can see here's
a B and C here I'm applying that same
thing to what's actually the the
function underlying this resource
function so if I have this resource
function here if I use symbol on on that
I there's an underlying function that's
ugly but that's sort of a symbol that
underlies this dependency graph resource
function and I can apply I can apply it
to itself and create this graph so you
can see all the other functions or
symbols that are that are dependent on
it so this is sort of a big
demonstration of a way to visualize your
code
again it's sort of sort of a gimmicky
esoteric thing that will be fun for
programmers but maybe not a system of
the Wolfram language thing so to to show
how all these things sort of fit
together and how all the repositories
are part of a integrated Wolfram
language system what I've done is sort
of combine all these different resource
types into this one example so here I'm
getting a data resource about our solar
system and I'm grabbing data about
Europa and I'm using arm using lookup
sequence that function that we had
before to grab data about Europa and
then I'm applying it to the the formula
for gravitational acceleration and when
we when that all works out we get you
know so wdf a quantity object of 1.3 one
meters per second squared
I can check Wolfram Alpha to see if if
we think that's correct
burn it yeah so down to down to some
rounding Wolfram Alpha and and the
resource system agree so so that's sort
of how everything is well integrated
together so the next thing we want to
look at is creating your own resource we
did this with the data repository in the
last presentation so now we're going to
do it with function repository something
that's brand-new now is the a definition
notebook for function resources so just
like data you can fill this out and to
create a function resource you can also
do it programmatically which is what I
what I have made in this in this
demonstration so here I have a function
I made called find a celebrity users
find faces - on an image to find an
image and then it uses classify to find
find a celebrity in that image and then
I use image trim on on on the faces and
it then applies this click pane so that
if you click on
a name that we put on the face it'll get
Wikipedia data and it'll print it out
for us so that that's that's a little a
little function I made it's not not too
complicated but it makes something sort
of fun if I if I click here it'll tell
me about Michael Jordan and I can use my
webcam to get a picture of me see you I
am sometimes the headset throws off the
classifier and I get something funny
Hunter s Thompson okay that's not too
bad
yeah okay so so now I have this function
I can create a function resource out of
it
just by just by adding a little bit of
metadata and here's here's my function
so I can go ahead and use this anywhere
in the in Wolfram language and it'll
work right away if I want to deploy this
or submit it I could add a few more
things like I can add some details and
some source metadata and I can create an
example notebook so here's this I have
some some simple examples that I created
beforehand that I'm just gonna replace
these default guys with this so here I
can oops wrong window here we go let's
put this in here and then if I do this
see if it gives me Tina Fey Courtney Cox
okay sitcom stars I guess so here we
have so that now I can cloud deploy it
and just like we saw with the data
resource you create a web page for your
resource object and these things are
copyable and you can share this with
with a colleague so and you know if you
give the your colleague this cloud
object they can just use resource object
directly on the cloud object and they
can use
their Wolfram language session so if you
have had a pub if you have a publisher
ID you can also submit this to the
resource system that will give you a
submission object and it'll and you'll
get a notification email that will tell
you that it's being reviewed I won't do
that right now because I don't want to
create things that I know will be
rejected so so that's a brief summary of
the resource system as it is now and
where it will be in the coming weeks
looking at a little bit further API
resources is a big project that we're
working on so we'll have api's deployed
it deployed in our cloud that you can
access to do computation of Pacolet
resources which is sort of like the big
brother of the function resources so
instead of just sort of a simple
function that you can write write in
it's a packet that has that can have
source libraries and notebooks and style
sheets and documentation and all sorts
of more robust behaviors device
connections for things that you could
like used on your Raspberry Pi running
Wolfram language to connect to something
over GPIO or you could connect to a
webcam or something service connections
if some of you might be familiar with
our service connect that connects to
things like Twitter and and you know
Facebook and RunKeeper and all these all
of these Web API so we're going to put
that into the resource system so that we
can have a web interface for those
things and then a big extension to the
resource system will be the marketplace
where we're going to add sort of buying
and selling to some of these resources
so a lot of like the stuff we already
have will stay free
but for users that are contributing
things
if we have some stuff that we're running
that really uses a lot of computation in
our cloud and we don't want to give it
all away for free then we're going to
add billing to it so that you can buy
access and if you have something cool
you can sell it and make some money
so that that summarizes the resource
system in general I have a few minutes
before I'm gonna have to turn things
over to Megan so we can go ahead and do
some more questions we can a feel free
to ask me things specific about data
repository if I didn't get to him before
let's see I have a question
our public functions checked for
dangerous content like delete file yes
absolutely
so for well for the function repository
yes absolutely yeah so like I said
everything that's submitted is it's
checked by by people and we're gonna
look at that and make sure that it's
that it's not malicious now a user can
cloud deploy anything they want to their
cloud account and they can send you a
link and say hey check this out and then
you know you got to make sure that the
person is sending to use legit just like
any other email you might ever get in
life but for things that are published
in our repository we will vet them and
you know there's sort of two steps to
that because like I said we're not
giving a publisher ID to just anyone who
asks and then so we so we know something
about the people who are submitting and
then each submission itself is manually
reviewed Laurent is asking all data
needs to fit in the memory right so
there's a max on the data set that's
right for the for the data repository
yeah the data all is read into memory at
once so yeah typically you don't want to
get anything more than you know a couple
hundred mega
i'ts for two reason for users to
reasonably be able to use it we have a
couple things that are probably bigger
than that and it's it's not the best
user experience on those things so
that's sort of a rough thing I sort of a
rough guideline of course it depends on
the the end user if they're if they're
trying to run Wolfen language on a
Raspberry Pi you're gonna want to much a
much smaller limit than if they're
running it on some beastly Linux machine